while Havana the capital is mainly
spurred Cubans throughout the country's
provinces are facing power cuts
Michelle Vega says he often has to put
up with six hour blackouts
when the lights go out you can't sleep
until it comes back I have an
eight-year-old child who has to go to
school the next day so I have to be by
his side keeping the mosquitoes at Bay
so he can sleep
it's an issue for the workforce too in
the all-important agriculture sector
production relies on power
we can't Crush sugar cane because we
need electricity and so if there's no
electricity we can't Mill the cane rots
you can't work you can't earn money
experts say it's a problem that's been
brewing for years Cuba's electric grid
is is old uh it's more than 35 to 40
years that's been operating uh so it's
all it's tired it's inefficient uh it's
obsolete
the system of the eight thermoelectric
power plants and 20 units right now for
example only about
40 percent are are working and operating
the island needs to update its rickety
infrastructure but it doesn't have the
money Cuba's energy crisis stems from
its deep economic crisis an inefficient
land economy and Fallout from the
pandemic are key factors but economists
say U.S sanctions make a bad situation
worse starving the country of billions
of dollars in Revenue now that's less
money to import fuel to build new power
plants and to invest in Renewables
the Communist party wants to avoid a
repeat of the summer 2021 protests when
tens of thousands hit the streets across
the island
those protests started after a 12-hour
power cut in a small Westerly Town and
then last August lightning struck the
country's main fuel Depot causing an
inferno and widespread blackouts
by last October the average Cuban
household was going 10 hours a day
without electricity
since then Cuba has leased more floating
power stations from Turkey
an expensive Band-Aid solution analysts
say but one that pumps more megawatts
into the system in the short term and
Russia is sending more petroleum to Cuba
to make up for ukraine-related sanctions
imposed by the US and Europe it's
helping but summer where energy demand
goes up is on the way and with blackouts
still a common occurrence and with more
shortages of both electricity and
liquefied gas expected some people here
are averting to Charcoal their patience
is being tested at Augustine Al Jazeera
camaway Cuba